the first thing that tips the foundation
off to scp-087's presence were the
reports of numerous
unexplained disappearances on campus
there were plenty of rumors about what
might be behind them
but field agents suspected that the true
source of the vanishing would be
something beyond
civilian imagination all anyone knew for
sure was that everyone who had gone
missing
was last seen in a certain
administrative building on the
university grounds
and that the disappearances only seemed
to happen when the elevator was out
the campus was soon flooded with
foundation agents creating a barrier
around the administrative building
and the presumed habitat of scp-087
nobody else could get in and hopefully
whatever was inside couldn't get out
one of the foundation's lead scientists
was flown in to consult on the
investigation
what could have been behind those
students disappearing the doctor's
preliminary interviews with university
staff who worked in the building
yielded some interesting details strange
noises
like banging and even a faint shrill
crying would be heard from a door that
led to a no longer used stairway
in hallway 3b staff in the building had
no reason to ever take these stairs
especially considering how many of them
reported the strange sense of unease
when just standing outside the door
the only reason someone might take those
stairs is due to
elevator malfunctions in that instant
the doctor had put it all together the
staff they interviewed had their memory
wiped with amnestics special chemicals
used by the foundation with the power to
delete human memories
the foundation only used them for staff
or civilians who had confirmed contact
with an scp
and the doctor knew that they had a live
one on their hands
the staircase there was something
terribly wrong with that staircase
and it was the scp foundation's job to
find out
what before it made anybody else
disappear
this is the story of scp-087
otherwise known as the endless staircase
and the three doomed journeys down
into its murky depths the doctor was
more than eager to begin research into
the staircase
and its frightening anomalous properties
after all
you don't claw your way up to being one
of the foundation's key researchers
without being brave
and perhaps just a little bit deranged
as with standard
once a perimeter was secured around the
staircase the good doctor requested a
selection of d-class personnel for
testing
for those not in the know d-class is the
foundation's polite way of saying
cannon fodder the doctor was sent three
d-class prisoners for use in his
investigation of scp-087
the first d-8432 was according to
official documentation on the incident
a 43 year old male of average build and
appearance
and unremarkable psychological
background this man once worked for the
foundation in a more official capacity
but he was given the often deadly
demotion to d-class due to a dangerous
mistake handling scp-682
that led to the deaths of several other
agents now
it looked like it would be his turn the
doctor explained his mission to him
explore the staircase gather data help
us find out exactly what we're dealing
with here
if you come back alive there may even be
a promotion in it for you and with that
promise
d8432 was given as loadout a 75 watt
flood lamp with battery power capable of
lasting
24 hours an audio headset and a handheld
camcorder fitted with a transmission
strain and an audio headset that would
allow him to communicate with dr bright
d-8432 was then pushed through the door
in hallway 3b
and out onto the staircase according to
declassified foundation files describing
the staircase
scp-087 is an unlit platform staircase
stairs descend on a 38 degree angle for
13 steps before reaching a semicircular
platform of approximately three meters
in diameter
descent direction rotates 180 degrees at
each platform
the design of scp-087 limits subjects to
a visual range of approximately 1.5
flights
but in d8432's mind unlit really didn't
seem like the right word
he would have chosen all-consuming
darkness
despite carrying a powerful 75-watt lamp
d-8432 was only capable of partially
lighting the platform he was standing on
and the illumination only stretched down
9 of the 13 steps to the next platform
when d8432 observed how little help his
lamp was giving him
he was instructed to shine it out of the
doorway into hallway 3b
when he did so the light seemed to shine
far further than it ever could in
scp-087
already the beginning of the anomalous
activity was obvious
everywhere else darkness is just the
absence of light
in scp-087 darkness eats light
it was like a tangible black mass that
only a certain amount of light could
survive
while the rest just wouldn't show d-8432
swallowed hard over a lump in his throat
the door to hallway 3b was closed behind
him and he was ordered to descend
surviving to see that promotion was
feeling unlikely but it's not like he
had a choice
if he tried to escape scp-087 before he
was permitted
he'd be shot by scp foundation field
agents on the spot so he followed the
high-ranking doctor's orders and began
to descend the steps to the next
platform
nothing about the physical makeup of the
staircase itself
seemed abnormal the base and walls were
a very plain dull concrete
with a metal handrail the only thing
that seemed unique about it so far was
the strange light-bending properties
that was until he reached the second
platform down
and he heard a soft echoing cry
a child's cry it was shrieks of panic or
maybe even pain
echoing up from below he was asked why
he had stopped
and he explained the crying sound he'd
been hearing it sounded like it was
coming from far
down the stairs maybe 200 meters below
him
he could just make out the words please
health and down here
coming from the darkness but the team
outside the stairwell couldn't hear
anything so they asked him to descend
further another platform down and they
could hear it too
the unmistakable cries of a terrified
child
please help and down here d8432 was
ordered to keep going
and only stop if he noticed changes to
the visual environment
or in the sounds he was hearing d8432
knowing his life was on the line had
to keep going and descended another 20
flights of stairs before stopping to
remark that the sounds of the child
hadn't gotten any closer
they still sounded just as far away as
when he'd first heard them
he was told his observations were noted
and pressured to continue
within half an hour d-8432 had descended
a full
50 floors with no sign of a bottom in
sight
somehow the volume of the child's crying
had remained consistent throughout
as if it was moving away from d-8432 at
the same rate he was descending
at this point d8432 reported that he was
feeling uneasy
the doctor said that this was
understandable given the circumstances
he'd been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire
time
and something about the truly bottomless
nature of the staircase and the ever
elusive crying
was undeniably eerie but things were
about to really take a turn for the
worst
as d8432 stepped forward towards the
next set of stairs
he froze there was something on the
platform below him
barely illuminated by the light of the
75 watt bulb
it was a face vaguely human in size and
shape
but with a few terrifying differences it
had grayish skin
and no mouth nostrils
and yet da432 could feel that this thing
was making
eye contact with him he couldn't move
trapped in the thing's piercing gaze
in an instant the face jerked forwards
suddenly only about a foot away from
d432's face
eyes staring into its own d8432 screamed
and ran
scaling all 50 flights in an astonishing
18 minutes
before charging out into hallway 3b
there he collapsed from the exhaustion
and the fear of what he'd just seen upon
reviewing the footage
the strange face was designated
scp-087-1
fascinating it was time for a second
experiment
the doctor just had to know more the
second test subject was d-9035
a 28-year-old male with a history of
aggravated assaults against women
he was given the same loadout as his
predecessors except this time
with an even more powerful 100 watt bulb
it was also given 100 small
led lights that had adhesive backs and a
battery life of approximately three
weeks
with which they intended to permanently
illuminate scp-087
however despite the extra wattage of his
bulb he still couldn't illuminate beyond
the ninth step
scp-087 wouldn't allow it having no
ideas of the horrors that lurked below
him
he descended on the doctor's orders and
began fixing the leds to the walls of
each platform he passed
the led always illuminated the landing
but the light couldn't pass the first
step on either side
the flights of stairs themselves would
remain in perpetual darkness
after the second flight d-9035 noticed
the same crying d8432 had heard and
became uneasy
just like before as d-9035 descended
the volume of the crying didn't seem to
increase as if for every step he
descended
the source of the crime descended one
two keeping them at a constant 200
meters apart
still he was ordered to continue his
descent and the placing of leds
even as his paranoia grew when he
reached the 51st floor
he observed damage to the wall and steps
sections appeared to have been smashed
to rubble by an extreme force
as he descended past the broken step he
only felt his fear
anxiety and paranoia grow the doctor
made note of the fact that scp-087
seemed to cause
instances of anxiety and terror in its
occupants even before they encountered
scp-087-1
as d-9035 reached platform 89
a full 350 meters under the initial
platform
he stopped dead in his tracks and saw
something staring up at him from the
platform below
that same terrible grey face with those
dead
white eyes he was encouraged to stay
calm and try to get better footage of
the face but it charged for him
and d-9035 ran for his life he ascended
the staircase at a staggering pace
even passing out from exhaustion and
remaining motionless for 14 minutes
halfway
when d-9035 finally gathered the
strength to get up
he scrambled back to hallway 3b and fell
into a state of catatonia
he remains unresponsive to all external
stimuli to this day
just staring off into the distance with
a haunt of expression
almost like he's still there in the
hallway the doctor wanted to conduct
one more test before he ordered scp-087
shut off from the world forever
and it was the most terrifying of all
the final subject was d-9884
a 23-year-old woman with a history of
depression and use of excessive force
the doctor had hoped that d-9884 would
travel the deepest yet
and so he gave her the additional
supplies of a backpack containing 3.75
liters of water
15 nutrient bars and one thermal blanket
as far as the foundation was concerned
she was in this
for the long haul but none of them had
any idea quite how right they were
when d9884 entered scp-087
all the lights from the previous
expedition had disappeared
still she was ordered to go deeper she
heard the crying of the mysterious child
if it was even a child at all and again
she was ordered to go deeper
at the 496th landing even as dean 9884
seemed to slip into a state of mortal
terror
once again she was ordered to go even
deeper
every moment he was hoping to get a
better look at the face of scp-087-1
and when d-9884 finally broke and fled
back upstairs
he did the face appeared but this time
it was mere inches behind her staring
directly into the camera
with its blank eyes startling even this
veteran of the supernatural
the face appearing caused dean 9884 to
panic and flee
but instead of going back up the stairs
to safety she went deeper down the
staircase in an attempt to escape it
deeper and deeper and deeper until her
video feed
cut out d-9884 was never seen
again in the aftermath of the tests the
scp was classified as euclid
it may have been dangerous but at least
it was easy to contain
the door to hallway 3b was replaced with
one made out of reinforced steel with an
electro release lock mechanism
it has been disguised to resemble a
janitorial closet consistent with the
rest of the building
the lock won't release unless a
classified number of electrical volts
are applied
while the key is turned counterclockwise
and after a few inches of foam
insulation were applied to the inner
side of the door
staff at the building never again
reported hearing strange noises
as for the fates of those lost within
the endless turning flights and
platforms of scp-087
we may never know but one can only
assume
it isn't pleasant
you